Identification.
It's station thirteen with faith banter and Karen
and Craig recorded on Thursday the fourth of September one thousand nine hundred seven
and the tapes are about to begin in another few seconds. So Carolyn looked at her mother.
And said Mom I think you better get texting go back to the hotel. And this is what happened.
So she put her mother into the text in the hotel. So they are in the party and Caroline and they are this. We said Oh.
I fear experienced on that trip. The storm broke the boat was overloaded.
It had far more people in it should have had plus and all the rocks which they take to the Ottomans and things
but I was sitting there hanging on like grim. From eight o'clock until five o'clock in the morning just to steal.
Otherwise I'd go overboard. And we were hanging onto each other's legs. And the women of course just.
Most of them very big help to hold them. And the but they don't. And the captain happened to come from.
He knew all about. And. We couldn't talk because you couldn't move except when I thought my hand held is no longer.
And I couldn't because I would have went overboard on the floor and pulled myself along.
To work with the toilet at the back of the sternest. And I pushed a little door open. It looked really. So I couldn't.
How did you know. And she threw up. Sure. And at five o'clock in the morning we had.
To be in for a car show which is one of them but my cabin. And what should happen. Is washed ashore.
We pull into this little room and the next thing the boat. And fortunately on the tree. I think they call a peaceful.
Young Irishman he was under on the boat and after the boat was stranded. We thought we were going to do.
And he said look I know the mission. The Presbyterian. You know it's a better.
And I think we should leave the back of it because the main got stuck into them. Here.
The crew got stuck into the beer
and Meredith who is with us had this magnificent long hair that you could sit on looking young woman nineteen
or twenty or whatever and I kept looking at her and saying fuck fuck. So Tony and I think we're very good and. So.
We took. We put our sleeping bags on my back and we set off and when it was as it were we climbed out.
And finally we came to a cottage and mission. And it happened.
Tony knew her because she had sheltered him on previous occasions. Lovely. She knew that we were coming.
I think someone who'd run ahead. And she'd knocked off her chicken.
And had cooked it in Ballard time we got there it was just ready to eat a woman of course you can imagine hadn't spoken
to anyone from Australia for a long time and she couldn't stop talking and I was rocking. And she put us all down to.
Have to read the chicken and. Then Tony said he'd just heard word from them but someone had come.
And said the tide would be.
We must have been shipwrecked about midnight because this person came up
and said the tide will be at five o'clock in the morning and if we're not on about the weather.
Which I haven't was this one. Yes said the nursing sister.
And we've actually ran to the bank because of being left on the. True enough leg but just ready to pull the anchor and.
I had to go when the tide came in. Otherwise.
So we got on the boat and the captain was able to talk to me he told me his name
and that he would come from my father's village and that he had rowed. And said that we were coming.
And I said thinking you know if this is work if this is what you get ready to give.
Well that have to do with your rived. It was beautiful.
And there on the beach was the whole village to welcome us and I was clapping and
when we actually got to come this way to pass through the spirit of beautiful. And I took us up to the valley.
They gave us some strong and I'd cleaned up the church in which they were going to. Mr Painter a moving moment for you.
It was a very moving experience because I was actually in the village that had.
When I was a child around the US and I never in my wildest dreams ever ever thought I would ever see this village.
I don't know why but it never occurred to me. I mean if you went somewhere. You went off to the M.R.O.
You know a lot of them know what have you in my head I'm pretty crazy leaving these beautiful islands behind them a
country. Anyhow. We stayed. And then came back and pictures have one afternoon in the with a head cow.
And we went back to the. But it wasn't before that they had given me a lot of information about my father's.
They remembered my father.
My father's family and then he said that they were his cousins and nieces and nephews and what have you.
I doubt if this was bad it was nice to be able to identify with each other and.
I've been looking at some of the photographs that were taken while there and I had my little type of code.
And the kids lost like I would say sing for me and
when I played it back they'd almost hop into the skin with excitement
and there was one particular little girl I would say she would be about six.
And she was very keen to press the button and I sit and watch. It. And she said.
And then there was another person who said her name was. Telly.
Now I have a sister who is second time as telly and she was named. After my father's mother.
So I felt you know this is my bloody family for God's sake.
Incidentally I moved just out of the church into the maternity clinic but they said if a pregnant woman comes in.
It would have to go back to the church but in the clinic there were facilities or showers. And so forth.
So we go up to the clinic and it's very nice apart from that we.
And various groups of people would come in from the mountains and. That was me.
And tell me some story about being related to me.
One morning we get up and sitting outside is a six foot plus with quite. A group of women.
Come in the morning with hot. Taro. Chicken or what have you. But there he was and he was nursing a rooster.
And so when I go out. This doesn't belong here with the rooster. It was very moving.
But I found that was the most important thing about. Any Have we went back to the hotel and Alan had left for.
We came back to Sydney and that inspired me to write for.
I didn't know I thought well the best thing to do is just put it. Put it. And I put it down.
And do you know if I could really do that again. I've become perhaps too sophisticated to work there.
I think if you play.
It just quite spontaneously Wolf when you start to write every word of every word and every morning I get how to work.
And at quarter past seven. I would be sitting down to right through the you know until about one o'clock.
And then I'd go back to it and get up in time to get dinner. And I kept there for them up. And then I gave it to.
Lovely person after Australia Council for governor second name. Doesn't matter. And.
The publisher for it and I couldn't believe it when I got in the manuscript.
He rang me up and asked me to have coffee with him.
And he brought the manuscript back and he said Well it's really not a book.
And I thought about that and I thought well it's a book with publishing. A manuscript. You know these are truly.
Among the more younger writers. But it was. Very much between the writers. Anyhow. Nearly fell over all.
Good good news. Well liked it was great and that was the beginning right.
And the person who was handling it is now I'm not. And he said have you got a copy and I said Yes I hear.
Do you really want that comma. Not touched. But yes. It came out of this couple of months later I have three.
To tell him he has won an award. And later would come in the post.
For this can't be true and sure enough it was talking so I went down to Melbourne for the celebration.
I'd had quite a number off with radio and television and so forth. And that was the beginnings of my writing. Caroline.
It's much harder to write now because the disciplined. I don't know what I want to kind of feel to let the.